[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est juste une mesure
ce ne sont pas quelques fausses notes
qui vont décourager les 144 guitariste
choisi pour jouer à l'unisson à
l'oratoire saint joseph
c'est tout ça sera l'orateur c'est
risible c'est ce qui m'excite c'est plus
ça a l'air de quelque chose d'un petit
peu sauté de spécial
l'idée est de cet homme tom brady qui a
composé une symphonie de 37 minutes pour
six groupes d'environ 25 guitariste en
réunissant autant de musiciens
le compositeur veut créer un mur du son
c'est fort mais le but n'est pas de nous
étonner tout le monde avec super fort on
n'est pas super fort c'est juste la
résonance de ces comme quasiment 1000
code qui résonne simultanément c'est
vraiment remarquable jusqu'à un
événement acoustique
ce guitariste pour la plupart des
amateurs ont pu pratiquer des semaines à
l'avance grâce à une vidéo mise en ligne
la partition d'omer exigeante même pour
ce musicien qui se fait de la corde sur
les doigts depuis près de 50 ans
1 on se trompe parce que là on y ranger
quelle mesure on le regarde la feuille
où en est sa bonne place t par une
mesure qu'on avance pas une maladie
qu'on apprend par coeur facilement mais
c'est juste le nether faut que ça coule
le compositeur tom brady a déjà organisé
de tels rassemblements mais avec moins
de guitaristes et il a justement tout
prévu les bonnes comme les mauvaises
notes
dès le début j'ai comme imaginer qu'on
va voir des erreurs donc j'ai composé
une musique avec un petit marge de
manoeuvre la phrase que j'ai concocté
pour vous présenter ça c'est là la
beauté spontanée de l'imperfection je
peux faire la diège l'abbé mal si bémol
parmi les rockeurs les plus âgés au rêve
deviendra réalité dimanche alors qu'ils
joueront au même endroit que le groupe
offenbach qui en 1972 avait donné une
messe électrique à l'oratoire saint
joseph
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
tout à fait parce que ça a été quand
même sans dire un blasphème à leurs fans
bac aller jouer à l'oratoire il ya
quelque chose qui fait à celle là dedans
trois quarts avec ses 144 guitare
électrique
le concert de dimanche présidera aussi
comme une tonne de briques
ici louis fait dépouiller mais
radio-canada mourir
[Musique]